i liken it to um seeing a parent with a
toddler like if you're at a restaurant
and the toddler is freaking out and
screaming
and there are the parents that give a
toddler what he wants and that's like
terrible
and white america when we when they see
these radicalized black people because
it's not all black people
but they get the attention right these
radicalized black people
screaming and wailing about something
they just give them what they want no
matter what it is defund the police okay
we'll just start talking about defining
the police because you've made that
ridiculous absurd demand that has never
been made ever
um and so i it's hard not to think that
this is actually the fault
of white guilt right this is this is
white guilt gone too far you guys are
like overdosing
on my guilt right now
all right well let's talk about the
other thing enough about kovid
uh racism candace it's everywhere
there's more of it
to go around than ever before it's a
miracle that they even let you use skype
right now as a black woman i mean what
do we do about this situation
i mean i think it is really time the
challenge now is to just
dear white people what the hell have you
been thinking allowing this to go on
this far you know what i mean at this
tail in between the legs
hey look my ancestors i can at least say
we were dragged with chains and whipped
and beaten into submission
white people today i don't even know
what this is this is crazy i mean i've
never seen such people
um that are just so willing uh to to
fight for their own oppression
right to say oh i shouldn't deserve it i
should step down from my job i shouldn't
be in this room i shouldn't be able to
say anything i should be silent for a
day
and it is just such an openly hostile
okay society um in terms of treating
white people poorly
and but white people have dug the grapes
so it's very bizarre to me and
you know i liken it to um seeing a
parent with a toddler like if you're at
a restaurant and the toddler is freaking
out and screaming
and there are the parents that give the
toddler what he wants and that's like
terrible and white america when we when
they see these radicalized black people
because it's not all black people
but they get the attention right these
radicalized black people
screaming and wailing about something
they just give them what they want no
matter what it is defund the police okay
we'll just start talking about defining
the police because you've made that
ridiculous observed demand that has
never been made ever um
and so i it's hard not to think that
this is actually the fault
of white guilt right this is this is
white guilt gone too far you guys are
like overdosing
on my guilt right now not me
hey not me lady i'm not guilty for
anything i haven't done
me personally but you know and so
um i always just ask please stop giving
the toddlers in the black community what
they want
and similarly i won't give your you know
freakish little antifa white thugs what
they want you know and
um and there just needs to be more
people having a bit of a spine i would
say in the white community
did you sense that this thing was coming
sort of like what we were always up
against when we would do college events
together
and it would be this odd sort of antifa
thing but we didn't know exactly what it
was and it was a little bit before
blm had like fully exposed itself to me
but
all of this and as i said to you in our
other interview and as we've always done
at every event we've ever done together
we take questions
from people who disagree with us first
but are you
shocked how quickly in the last six
months
this thing like molded together and blm
and antifa and the marxists and the
twitter
like the whole thing just morphed into
one really evil monster
really freaking fast all sort of under
the coved thing like it all happened at
the same time
right um i wasn't shocked i mean i have
been warning about this for
years i kept saying during an election
cycle you're going to see race issues
drummed up
now how violent they've gotten yes that
surprised me
um and also i would say i've been
shocked by the permission they've been
given and the excuses and the passes
they've been given
by politicians i never foresaw that
coming i would think a store gets robbed
looted uh torn down burned and you know
no matter whether you're left or right
you know you would stand up and say this
is wrong the inability for politicians
to now acknowledge what's right and
what's wrong that has shocked me
uh we've hit a real low point when um
people are saying this is okay when
politicians don't have the spine and say
you know what i'm actually not okay with
finding the police
and we need to isolate this incident and
compromise this incident
and not say that every police officer is
wrong um
and so i i am shocked at how much the
left hates
america um and how much the left
hates people that do the right thing
because that's really what it's come
down to if you do the right thing if you
earn accolades in life if you
you know climb the ladder in life they
hate you uh and they're saying there's
not a place for you anymore if there's
something fundamentally wrong with free
markets with capitalism with
everything that american and western
ideals and western principles were built
upon
so that part shocked me but not this
narrative i i was seeing it everywhere i
went and i knew that they were organized
that they were well funded and that they
were going to come ready to fight
yeah do you how do you see
any chance of getting out of this thing
i mean as you said you you expect trump
to win
i think you would think he's going to
win big i think he's probably going to
win big too
and it's like no matter if biden wins if
trump wins if biden wins big if trump
wins big
it's sort of like i don't see a way we
get out of this either way i could see
some version maybe where if trump wins
by
truly a landslide like a like a reagan
re-election situation
that maybe finally the last few decent
democrats
get the kids out of the adult table like
the kids that they've let taken over
that's sort of what you were saying
before
maybe they do it themselves but that
doesn't seem
very probable to me do you see any way
we get out of this thing
well the only way we get out of it is if
people and i think we are
actually gonna are starting out of it
now in a weird way because people are
starting to see socialism manifest
right marxist principles manifest
they're looking around their
neighborhoods
and they're seeing you know uh stores
being looted stores being robbed
violence happening police getting shot
individual
uh cities that are gone up in crime by
something like 267 percent
right in new york city and in chicago um
and they're seeing that the suburbs are
now being threatened they're going to
come to the suburbs they're telling
people in the suburbs to leave their
house
you saw i'm sure the video clip of maybe
you didn't because you were away but
uh throughout dc they were going up to
white people at restaurants and
oh yeah i've seen it
you know black power or else you get
screamed at so these people are now
seeing
you've supported this and now you've
seen what it's become and i think that
once those people understand now not
once they see that manifest they'll
change their perspective
and they'll they'll vote differently
right and then of course once the
democrats
if the democrats lose a ton of seats it
no longer serves them
to to be funding these marxist moves no
longer serves them to stand behind the
violent criminals
no longer serves them uh to pretend that
these criminals
were righteous and you'll see a dramatic
change in society and i think that it
will secure
as it did in england if i'm hoping to
see what we saw in england
where after brexit it just every every
vote went to the tory party
um i think that we will see the same
thing in america and we'll save this
country for a lot of time to come
because people will not forget this
yeah i i sense you're kind of right you
know i hate
when they say the gay community the
black community the community thing i
hate that
but you know i saw this poll just since
i've been back that at one point
i guess post the convention 24
of black people were thinking about
voting for trump historically we're
looking at like
four percent you know i tweeted
something like a year ago that i thought
trump was going to get 30
of the black vote and i know that might
be a little crazy but i still i think
that
the the mask has been pulled off and i i
think something crazy is going to happen
i really do
are you with me on that 100 you know
i've been saying this forever
and i was laughed at in the beginning
right when i first said blexit and
i said that that my vision had always
been 20 points by 2020. i knew it was
possible
because the left can no longer hide from
itself and i was so happy when aoc hit
the map
uh because she was just saying it you
know what i mean the the old school
democrats were good at hiding what they
wanted
and then aoc kind of took over their
party and said no this is what we want
and they capitulated to what she was
saying
and so they couldn't lie anymore right
they couldn't lie about the fact that
they were supporting these marxist
principles
and the destruction of family black
lives matter on the website destruct the
nuclear family
you know this is wrong this is backwards
so and i've just seen so many people
people you least suspect that have
contacted me privately celebrities
that you would just go this person
posted a black square this person's a
marxist and just going
i've had an awakening and i i would like
to have a private conversation with you
offline
um and i think that that to me it just
made me feel
just so happy like all of this hasn't
been for not all the beatings that i've
taken
uh it hasn't been for naught if you're
looking for more honest and thoughtful
conversations about politics instead of
non-stop yelling check out our politics
playlist and if you want to watch full
interviews on a variety of topics watch
our full episode playlist all right over
here
and to get notified of all future videos
be sure to subscribe and click the
notification bell